has your sort of imagination been
captivated by you mentioned DPT and all
the bigger and bigger and bigger
language models
and uh what are the limits
of those models do you think
so just the task of natural language
basically the way GPT is trained right
is you just download a mass amount of
text Data from the internet and you try
to predict the next word in the sequence
roughly speaking you're predicting will
work chunks but uh roughly speaking
that's it and what's been really
interesting to watch is
uh basically it's a language model
language models have actually existed
for a very long time
um there's papers on language modeling
from 2003 even earlier can you explain
that case what a language model is uh
yeah so language model just basically
the rough idea is um just predicting the
next word in a sequence roughly speaking
uh so there's a paper from for example
bengio and the team from 2003 where for
the first time they were using a neural
network to take say like three or five
words and predict the
um next word and they're doing this on
much smaller data sets and the neural
net is not a Transformer it's a
multi-air perceptron but but it's the
first time that a neural network has
been applied in that setting but even
before neural networks there were
language models except they were using
engram models so engram models are just
a count based models so
um if you try to if you start to take
two words and predict the third one you
just count up how many times you've seen
any two word combinations and what came
next and what you predict as coming next
is just what you've seen the most of in
the training set and so language
modeling has been around for a long time
neural networks have done language
modeling for a long time so really
what's new or interesting or exciting is
just realizing that when you scale it up
with a powerful enough neural net
Transformer you have all these emergent
properties where basically what happens
is if you have a large enough data set
of text
you are in the task of predicting the
next word you are multitasking a huge
amount of different kinds of problems
you are multitasking understanding of
you know chemistry physics human nature
lots of things are sort of clustered in
that objective it's a very simple
objective but actually you have to
understand a lot about the world to make
that prediction you just said the U word
understanding uh are you in terms of
chemistry and physics and so on what do
you feel like it's doing is it searching
for the right context
uh in in like what what is it what is
the actual process Happening Here Yeah
so basically it gets a thousand words
and it's trying to predict a thousand at
first and uh in order to do that very
very well over the entire data set
available on the internet you actually
have to basically kind of understand the
context of of what's going on in there
yeah
um and uh it's a sufficiently hard
problem that you uh if you have a
powerful enough computer like a
Transformer you end up with uh
interesting Solutions and uh you can ask
it uh to all do all kinds of things and
um it it shows a lot of emerging
properties like in context learning that
was the big deal with GPT and the
original paper when they published it is
that you can just sort of uh prompt it
in various ways and ask it to do various
things and it will just kind of complete
the sentence but in the process of just
completing the sentence it's actually
solving all kinds of really uh
interesting problems that we care about
do you think it's doing something like
understanding
like and when we use the word
understanding for us humans
I think it's doing some understanding it
in its weights it understands I think a
lot about the world and it has to in
order to predict the next word in a
sequence
so let's train on the data from the
internet
uh what do you think about this this
approach in terms of data sets of using
data from the internet do you think the
internet has enough structured data to
teach AI about human civilization
yeah so I think the internet has a huge
amount of data I'm not sure if it's a
complete enough set I don't know that uh
text is enough for having a sufficiently
powerful AGI as an outcome
um of course there is audio and video
and images and all that kind of stuff
yeah so text by itself I'm a little bit
suspicious about there's a ton of things
we don't put in text in writing uh just
because they're obvious to us about how
the world works in the physics of it and
that Things fall we don't put that stuff
in text because why would you we share
that understanding
and so Texas communication medium
between humans and it's not a
all-encompassing medium of knowledge
about the world but as you pointed out
we do have video and we have images and
we have audio and so I think that that
definitely helps a lot but we haven't
trained models uh sufficiently uh across
both across all those modalities yet so
I think that's what a lot of people are
interested in but I wonder what that
shared understanding of like well we
might call Common Sense
has to be learned
inferred in order to complete the
sentence correctly
so maybe the fact that it's implied on
the internet the model is going to have
to learn that not by reading about it by
inferring it in the representation so
like common sense just like we I don't
think we learn common sense like nobody
says
tells us explicitly we just figure it
all out by interacting with the world
right so here's a model of reading about
the way people interact with the world
it might have to infer that I wonder
yeah uh you you briefly worked on a
project called the world of bits
training in our RL system to take
actions on the internet
versus just consuming the internet like
we talked about do you think there's a
future for that kind of system
interacting with the internet to help
the learning yes I think that's probably
the uh the final frontier for a lot of
these models because
um so as you mentioned I was at open AI
I was working on this project called the
bits and basically it was the idea of
giving neural networks access to a
keyboard and a mouse and the idea could
possibly go wrong so basically you you
perceive the input of the screen pixels
and basically the state of the computer
is sort of visualized for human
consumption in images of the web browser
and stuff like that and then you give
the neural or the ability to press
keyboards and use the mouse and we're
trying to get it to for example complete
bookings and you know interact with user
interfaces and um where'd you learn from
that experience like what was some fun
stuff this is super cool idea yeah I
mean it's like
uh yeah I mean the the step between
Observer to actor yeah is a super
fascinating step yeah well the universal
interface in the digital realm I would
say and there's a universal interface in
like the Physical Realm which in my mind
is a humanoid form factor kind of thing
we can later talk about Optimus and so
on but I feel like there's a
they're kind of like a similar
philosophy in some way where the human
the world the physical world is designed
for the human form and the digital world
is designed for the human form of seeing
the screen and using keyword keyboard
and mouse and so as the internal
Universal interface that can basically
command the digital infrastructure we've
built up for ourselves and so it feels
like a very powerful interface to to
command and to build on top of now to
your question as to like what I learned
from that it's interesting because the
world of bits was basically uh too early
I think at open AI at the time
this is around 2015 or so and the
Zeitgeist at that time was very
different in AI from the Zeitgeist today
at the time everyone was super excited
about reinforcement learning from
scratch this is the time of the Atari
paper where uh neural networks were
playing Atari games and beating humans
in some cases uh alphago and so on so
everyone's very excited about training
neural networks from scratch using
reinforcement learning
um directly
it turns out that reinforcement learning
is extremely inefficient way of training
neural networks because you're taking
all these actions and all these
observations and you get some sparse
rewards once in a while so you do all
this stuff based on all these inputs and
once in a while you're like told you did
a good thing you did a bad thing and
it's just an extremely hard problem you
can't learn from that you can burn
forest and you can sort of Brute Force
through it and we saw that I think with
uh you know with go and DOTA and so on
and does work but it's extremely
inefficient uh and not how you want to
approach problems practically speaking
and so that's the approach that at the
time we also took to World of bits we
would uh have an agent initialize
randomly so with keyboard mash and mouse
mash and try to make a booking and it's
just like revealed the insanity of that
approach very quickly where you have to
stumble by the correct booking in order
to get a reward of you did it correctly
and you're never going to stumble by it
by chance at random
so even with a simple web interface
there's too many options there's just
too many options uh and uh it's two
parts of a reward signal and you're
starting from scratch at the time and so
you don't know how to read you don't
understand pictures images buttons you
don't understand what it means to like
make a booking but now what's happened
is uh it is time to revisit that and
open your eyes interested in this uh
companies like Adept are interested in
this and so on and uh the idea is coming
back because the interface is very
powerful but now you're not training an
agent from scratch you are taking the
GPT as an initialization so GPT is
pre-trained on all of text and it
understands what's a booking it
understands what's a submit it
understands um quite a bit more and so
it already has those representations
they are very powerful and that makes
all the training significantly more
efficient and makes the problem
tractable should the interaction be with
like the way humans see it with the
buttons and the language or it should be
with the HTML JavaScript and this and
the CSS what's what do you think is the
better so today all this interest is
mostly on the level of HTML CSS and so
on that's done because of computational
constraints but I think ultimately
everything is designed for human visual
consumption and so at the end of the day
there's all the additional information
is in the layout of the web page and
what's next to you and what's a red
background and all this kind of stuff
and what it looks like visually so I
think that's the final frontier as we
are taking in pixels and we're giving
out keyboard mouse commands but I think
it's impractical still today